okay we're going to begin with breaking
news and Russian hackers are accused of
trying to steal research from several
institutions developing a covert 19
vaccine the UK the US and Canada say
hackers are quote almost certainly part
of Russian intelligence services it's
alleged they've been targeting academic
and pharmaceutical institutions since
the start of the pandemic okay let's go
live to Paul Brennan in London let's
talk about this situation first of all
what more do we know well a lot of
attention about Russia's cyber attacks
and activities in the recent days and
there'll be more next week as well but
looking at this specific claim and this
specific report I have it the documents
in front of me it's an advisory that's
been issued by the UK's national
cybersecurity Center it's 14 pages long
and what it essentially says is that a
hacker group called apt 29 also known in
some circles as the dukes of haps better
known to the general public as cozy bear
has been throughout 2020 mounting a wide
range of cyber attacks scanning
organizations for vulnerabilities we're
talking about governmental organizations
diplomatic think tanks and and
healthcare organizations scanning those
organizations for vulnerabilities and
among the organizations that have been
targeted by this group according to this
advisory organizations that are involved
in developing a vaccine for coronavirus
wachovia 19 what it says in the advisory
is that app 29 has targeted
organizations responsible for vaccine
development in both the UK the United
States and in Canada and why well they
say it's highly likely with the
intention of stealing information and
intellectual property relating to the
development and testing of vaccines
they've been using a whole range of
various custom-made malware such as well
mess and well mail and also spear
phishing as well which targets
individuals and tries to get them to
give over details and it's a very
serious allegations about the the
director of the national cybersecurity
Center here in the UK has described it
as despicable the
so it's um it's it's really serious
stuff okay I want to come back to you in
a second Paul but let's go over to
Kimberly höckert who's our White House
correspondent Kimberly what kind of
reaction is the use us having to this
because of course it was one of the
countries that allegedly has been
targeted by this group yeah you know
this story really has just developed and
there has been no reaction thus far
except that the National Security Agency
has confirmed it but Paul did already
report that so really the details that
are out right now I can reiterate is
that you know for a long time the US
president has touted that a vaccine is
imminent certainly this is going to be a
concern that the fact that there is this
group apt 29 also known as cozy bear
that may be undermining those efforts as
Paul reported Russia may be working not
just in the United States not just in
the UK but also in Canada this is
something that has been corroborated by
intelligence services in all three
nations and the concern is that that
these are techniques that many people
fall prey to very easily even those that
have been warned in advance spearfishing
for example sophisticated malware and
again this has been confirmed to be part
of the Kremlin intelligence services so
given the fact that there has been this
ongoing fear of interference in the
United States whether it be the 2016 US
election whether it be fear about the
2020 election or whether it be fear
about vaccine research the concern is is
that this would hinder the development
of a vaccine something that right now
officials say is not the case but
certainly the susceptibility the fact
that there may be intelligence that has
already been retrieved as a result of
these sophisticated techniques that is
going to be a concern of the Trump
administration exactly and of course
we've the hacking is a big issue at the
moment particularly because we saw that
significant hack of of Twitter just in
the last few hours which they're
continuing to diagnose but for now
Kimberly Hager thank you very much
indeed I want to go back to Paul Brennan
in London let's move on a little bit but
it's around about the same theme
allegations from the UK
Russia has sought to influence the UK
elections what more can you tell us
about that yes it's important to see
this kovat 19 attack your vulnerability
scanning as part of a bigger picture
here just today the foreign secretary
here in the UK Dominic Robb has come out
and announced that there's evidence that
there was Russian interference attempted
interference in the 2019 general
election here in the UK how well the
statement he says the government's
concluded is almost certain that Russian
actors sought to interfere through the
online amplification of illicitly
acquired and leaked government documents
the documents were talking about here
are US UK trade documents which appeared
to share while certainly labour claimed
the opposition party claimed they showed
that the NHS the health surface was up
for sale well once those documents were
leaked it appears according to the
government that Russian agents Russian
actors then sought to give that
credibility and give that momentum by
way of influencing the outcome of the
election and the other part of it of
course is while we're waiting for the
results of the publication of a report
by Britain's Intelligence and Security
Committee which is due to report next
week although could have reported months
ago but it's a but a long delayed report
into whether or not there was any
Russian interference in the 2016 brexit
vote and the 2017 general election so
this three elections three votes here in
the UK that Russia may have had an
influence over and you can see that's
not just about Cozy per targeting
coronavirus vaccines there is a bigger
picture here that is causing grave
concern for intelligence and
cybersecurity experts
Paul the timing of this is interesting
as well because of course it's coming on
the basis of some changes within the
government with in relation to the way
that intelligence is handled and all and
also this is moving forward as you say
as part of wider investigations into
longer term allegations of Russian
interference yes I mean that report that
that long awaited long delayed report
could have been published before that
20 19 general election after reporting
to the brexit vote in the 2017 general
election and there was a lot of angst by
the chairman of that committee when it
was prevented from publishing the report
before the 2019 general election the
Committee Chairman felt there was a lot
of information in there that the voters
really should know it was stopped from
being published lots of question marks
about that now though the government
Boris Johnson the prime minister wanted
to install a chairman of his choice on
that committee with the belief it seems
from outside circles that it was to kind
of water down the the outcome of it the
findings however the Boris Johnson was
outmaneuvered a chairman has been voted
in who is not a pet of the Conservative
Party here in the UK and so the report
will be published next week and we are
waiting with some keen interest as to
exactly what it's going to say that's
Paul Brennan talking to us from London
Paul thank you very much indeed